Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my video for the boys
season 2 episode 7
it was diabolical if you're new to the
channel i'm doing videos for all the
episodes this season
be sure to subscribe to get everything
we'll also have some season 3 stuff
coming up real soon too
we're doing an amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite crazy moment
from the episode on the video so careful
for spoilers obviously from episode 7 if
you haven't seen it yet we'll do top 10
and comic book easter eggs as we go
along and there was a lot of comic book
stuff going on during the episode
starting with number 10 the intro with
the guy getting brainwashed by all of
stormfront's social media programming
watch out for that facebook feed that'll
get you
the episode basically starts with that
guy just waking up in his bedroom
in his home he lives with his mother and
it looks like he's a stormfront fanboy
and just
spends all day on facebook just reading
his social media feeds twitter
everywhere
and he's just soaking in everything that
she's doing with her social media push
until he learns the convenience store
clerk is a superhero that he's been
seeing this whole time
and he's convinced that he's a terrorist
because stormfront's rhetoric has been
telling him that so he winds up killing
him
later in the episode she winds up
throwing this guy under the bus
too using him for her campaign so it
just shows you how much she manipulates
people number nine pretty big celebrity
guest star john noble from fringe and a
bunch of other stuff
guest stars as butcher's father so
butcher's mother has to trick him
into coming to her apartment in new york
city to meet his father
because they have such a strained
relationship you learn all about
butcher's backstory and obviously you
kind of see what they're doing this for
they're trying to create a parallel
between his upbringing with his
domineering father who sounds like he
mistreated him maybe he physically
abused him and his younger brother you
also find out what happened to his
younger brother and how he died
and it gives you a sort of parallel for
homelanders upbringing with vogelbaum
because vogelbaum later in the episode
talks about how crappy he was when he
was raising homelander i needed him to
be the strongest man in the world
but you basically find out that butcher
blames his father for his younger
brother's death i know there were a lot
of theories about what was going on with
butcher's younger brother but you
learned that he wound up killing himself
he probably just became super depressed
maybe he had some sort of psychological
condition
and his father also tries to pin some of
the blame on
butchers saying that he went to join the
sas before his brother wound up killing
himself so butcher's been carrying this
around this whole time with him and
that's where a lot of his darkness flows
from why he's so hardcore
number eight bunch of bad parents in the
episode starlight meets up with her
mother but her mother
inadvertently gets them captured by
black noir by calling it in to vots
tower oh i talked to ashley no mom you
don't understand i'm trying to be on the
dl
while this is all going on you have
frenchie and kimiko's storyline they
weren't in the episode that much but
they're just there protecting the
congresswoman they do bond a little bit
so their relationship is on the mend and
she starts to teach him that special
sign language that she had with her
brother so
i think eventually by the end of the
season they will have some sort of
relationship together
you also have all the stuff going on on
the side with the deep in the church of
the collective and a train
i'm surprised that a train is sticking
around for all that stuff but you
remember they're kind of holding all
this stuff over him like we'll help you
get back into the seven
if you do what we tell you to do
otherwise we're going to throw you to
the wolves
they have this funny storyline with
eagle the archer remember he's meant to
be their hawkeye avengers parody the guy
that was helping indoctrinate the deep
into the church in the first couple of
episodes
and they just throw him right under the
bus the funny explainer that he gives at
the end of the episode though when
they're watching him at the bar
is that he refused to cut his mother out
of his life but at the party for the
church leader he just completely 180s on
him and the deep just kind of nods his
head and goes along with it so i'm
actually kind of wondering if a train is
going to be the one to eventually
save the deep from this cult he also
references a meeting that he's going to
be having with stan edgar really soon
maybe they'll pay that off but the way
they ended the episode kind of makes you
wonder
there's this whole big story line going
on with the church so i'm hoping that
they pay that off in some funny way by
the finale
number seven all the adult movie
parodies of the seven that lamplighter
makes huey watch with him
there's one for translucent the queen
made one is called queen made pleasure
slave a reference that they pay off
later in the episode
which itself is a comic book easter egg
big black noir which is another
reference that they pay off later in the
episode when maeve rips his mask off
revealing what he looks like underneath
the mask
then his starlight pulls an a train and
that's the one that puts huey over the
edge he's like
no more please please don't make me
watch any more of these movies
sean ashmore was great in this episode
you could just kind of tell that he knew
that he was going to die
very soon he's like i'm either going to
die at the trial or vought is going to
come get me homelanders going to come
get me
or black noir is going to come get me he
does not care at all but it is funny to
watch huey talk him into helping him
save starlight oh we're going to go get
the wife consensually
the whole thing with starlight is they
were keeping her in that superhero proof
cell that they have inside vought's
tower so you do have to imagine that
black noir
does this a lot like he goes around and
takes down other superheroes that go
rogue or really anybody that
wants to get rid of he's sort of their
private hitman inside the seven so
that's why he's the one that goes after
starlight at the beginning of the
episode and the one that tries to take
her down after she escapes from her cell
lamplighter makes a bunch more jokes
about sneaking college girls in the
secret entrance he also tells them about
hanging out with marathon
who's the person that a train wound up
replacing on the seven
number six homelander and stormfronts
rally in front of the soldier boys
statue so they're trying to pump up the
crowd against the congresswoman from
earlier that also shows up at the trial
later in the episode
and they go on and on about thoughts and
prayers it's all this rhetoric that
sounds very familiar if you know what
they're talking about but the big
soldier boy easter egg is that he's
actually going to be played by jensen
ackles during season 3.
there's supposedly some crazy storyline
they have planned for him
but he's basically their in-universe
version of captain america from the
avengers
soldier boy is supposed to be the first
american experiment in creating a
superhero now he wasn't super successful
but the storyline for season 3 that they
have planned for him is supposed to
explain that and i think it's going to
be different from the comic book soldier
boy story
stormfront has to explain to homelander
why keeping starlight alive is more
valuable to their tactics their grand
plan
she genuinely gets all misty-eyed at the
sight of a baby girl just because she's
thinking about her daughter who died
recently
so homelander naturally being the good
boyfriend that he is wants to cheer her
up
tells her about ryan so obviously this
is huge number five
homelander takes stormfront to see ryan
i feel like everybody could kind of
guess where this was headed the minute
you saw stormfront
look at ryan she gives becca the
business left and right trying to
undermine her with
every single word that comes out of her
mouth there's this really funny moment
though when they're watching the lego
movies that ryan made and homelander is
about to tell him that they're crappy
movies and you can see stormfront stare
some daggers at him like no you have to
tell him that it's a good movie
you need to encourage your son but the
movie that they're playing is actually
based on the blind side he just talks
about a bunch of other movies that he
created they're all very positive movies
he seems like he's a very creative child
but stormfront
kind of starts to work her magic her
insidious magic saying do you do any
normal kid stuff and she actually talks
about video games she even name draws
pewdiepie which was hilarious i thought
it was funny that he would show up in a
boys episode
then they start to plant the idea of the
movies that homelander has appeared in
trying to turn ryan into a superhero
fanboy so that eventually he'll want to
be a superhero with them and use his
powers
you can kind of see the way they're
trying to manipulate the situation they
want him to be excited to become a
superhero someday
it still feels like it's really early in
the ryan storyline with all the super
boy stuff that's going on so i'm
wondering how much of that is going to
spill into season three there's still so
much that could happen in the finale
but number four homelander and
stormfront then take off
with ryan so home leonard's stormfront
has shown ryan the truth they take him
up in the air so that he can see that
his neighborhood is fake everything is
fake you're fake mom
stormfront even basically tells becca to
her face that she's going to be ryan's
new mom now
the reason why this is a big deal is it
sounds like ryan might become a more
important character in the future
just remember everything there's still
so much that they could do with his
character
now he kind of seems like he wants to be
a superhero a little bit or maybe learn
about his powers so i'm hoping that they
deal with that in a much bigger way
during season three
but number three butcher forces
vogelbaum to testify against vought so
after mallory and mother's milk come to
visit him
and don't quite get what they need and
she tells mother's milk that he should
basically take off with his family
butcher comes back to meet him and just
gives him the business
sipping tea as menacingly as you could
possibly do
the reason why this is super important
is because their ace in the hole
lamplighter winds up burning himself
alive later in the episode i love
butcher's reaction to that too oh don't
worry i got it all sorted out
the crazy thing about their conversation
is that when vogelbaum is telling him
about homelanders origin story
homelander actually started out as a
really good kid when he was around five
or six like he says he loved davy
crockett stories he loved the woods
manifest destiny
but then because they needed him to be
the world's most powerful superhero
he started to quote unquote work on him
so vogelbaum really is to blame
for homelander being the psychopath that
he is in present day
but when butcher sort of turns it on him
and says i'll kill your entire family
like he turns on a dime the same way
that homelander would so they want
butcher to be a bit of a parallel for
homelander
it is weird that vogelbaum is surprised
by that how could you be such a monster
when he literally just told
butcher that he was a monster when he
was raising homelander
but number two starlight versus black
noir huey in lamplighter so lamplighter
takes huey to the main conference room
instead of to starlight cell because we
find out that he wanted to kill himself
in front of his statue
that the seven which they had already
replaced bumming him out so r.i.p
sean ashmore is just funny to see him go
from the x-men movies to playing such a
hardcore character who's a bit of a
parody on the pyro character from the
x-men movies but if you haven't read the
boys comic book the lamplighter
character in the comics is meant to be
more of a green lantern easter egg
huey has to saw his hand off so that he
can get around they kind of play it for
a joke a little bit later like wait a
minute is that a human hand that you're
walking around with
uh yeah okay we need to go then black
noir and starlight have a proper
superhero fight because they're both
super strong they trash the place
black noir almost kills her because he
is a badass but queen maeve winds up
saving her
with an almond joy turns out those
allergies will really get you so watch
out
but the real big deal here though is
them ripping his face mask off and
showing you what he looks like
underneath so his face is scarred from a
lot of that burn damage which is
probably from earlier in the season when
he took down that energy-based superhero
but if it wasn't clear before he is an
african-american so i think it changes a
lot of people's expectations for the
storyline for the black noir character i
think they're going to be changing that
from the comics
he's a very big very critical comic book
character so now just suggest
all your fan theories based on that but
if you have read the comics please don't
post any black noir spoilers in the
comments because they still might wind
up doing some of that for the tv show
then obviously number one is the
trial at the end of the episode
butcher gets vocal bomb to come testify
but right as he gets ready to speak
everyone's heads start exploding left
and right both superheroes and regular
people
r.i.p shockwave you have to remember
that this is happening on national
television so potentially millions of
people are watching this all go down
but if you look at stormfront and
homelanders faces they don't seem that
surprised by it so it sounds like they
know
what's going on and it's all part of
some plan that they had they'll probably
spin it as some sort of terrorist attack
and try to use it as part of their
compound v campaign that they're on
they've been a lot of theories about who
that superhero is that's exploding all
those heads but obviously it is a
superhero with the ability to do that
the only person we've seen with that
ability was cindy from a couple episodes
ago remember she was hitching a ride at
the end of that episode when she escaped
so it's possible that she came back and
she's doing this as far as we know
shockwave is the only super that they
killed in that room ashley is still okay
the congresswoman and mallory are still
okay in butcher as he's reacting to it
all just seems like he is ready to go
to war with a vengeance and i can't wait
to see what crazy thing he winds up
doing in the finale
but the important thing to remember is
there'll probably be some sort of
cliffhanger moment in the finale because
the boyz has already been renewed for
season three and it'll probably go to
season four
and hopefully season five as well but
let me know in the comments what your
favorite moment from the episode was and
if you spotted any big easter eggs that
i didn't mention in the video
my finale video will post next friday
just like i would normally post my
episode videos
and in a couple weeks the mandalorian
season 2 episodes will be starting i'll
be doing videos for that and then we'll
get avengers one division episodes later
this year so there's a bunch of big
stuff coming up
as long as you have alerts enabled for
my channel you should see all those
videos when i post them
earlier today it was announced that
marvel is going to be crossing
characters over from andrew garfield's
amazing spider-man movies with
spider-man 3 and tom holland
click here to learn about that and click
here for my boys season 2 episode 6
video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!